كانت الشوارع هنا شبه مهجورة بحلول
وقت مبكر من بعد الظهر ، لم يكن هناك أي
مطاعم مفتوحة كانت مشغولة الأسبوع
الماضي مغلقة تمامًا وبعد التصوير في
جميع أنحاء المدينة خرجت لتناول الغداء
لفريقنا بعد نصف ساعة من
المشي ، المكان الوحيد الذي رأيته مفتوحًا
كان  كان مقهى القطط
بالداخل عبارة عن عائلة تفر من الغزو الروسي بشكل واضح ،
وكان لديهم حقائب ظهر عملاقة ،
كل أنواع البطانيات التي تعرفها عليها
ترتدي أكبر عدد ممكن من طبقات ملابسهم
ولكنهم كانوا يبتسمون
لأنهم
رأوا العجلة التي لا يمكنك النظر إليها
ولا تبتسم و  اليوم ، احتاج أي إنسان في
هذا البلد إلى هدية الابتسامة
، اتضح أن هناك 20 قطة في ذلك
المقهى ، أخبرني أصحابها
القطط الجميلة حسن التصرف لماذا كان المقهى مفتوحًا
عندما كان كل شيء آخر مغلقًا
والناس هنا على حافة الهاوية و
قالت زوجة المالك إنها خائفة جيدًا لأن الأمر
بسيط إذا ذهبنا ، فلن يطعم أحد
قططنا ولن نغادر أوكرانيا أبدًا ،
فهم يبقون لأنهم يحبون حيواناتهم الأليفة
وقد جعلني ذلك أدرك  في تلك
اللحظة التي ظل فيها الناس لعدة
أسباب مختلفة وبالنسبة لي الزوجان
اللذان بقيا بسبب
حبهما لقططهما ، كان مجرد شعاع صغير من
السطوع على ما كان بالنسبة لنا جميعًا
هنا يومًا رائعًا ومظلمًا.